how great people think on april 16 2000
the New England Patriots drafted an
extra quarterback at a Michigan State
they'd scouted him thoroughly and had
their eye on him for some time seeing
that he was still available they took
him
it was a six-round and a 199 pick of the
draft the young quarterbacks name was
Tom Brady he was fourth string at the
beginning of his rookie season by his
second season he was a starter New
England won the Super Bowl that year
Brady was named MVP in terms of return
on investment it's probably the single
greatest draft pick in the history of
football for Super Bowl rings out of six
appearances 13 starting seasons 160 wins
392 touchdowns three Super Bowl MVPs
53,000 yards 10 Pro Bowls and more
division titles than any quarterback in
history it's not even finished paying
dividends Brady may still have many more
seasons left at him so you'd think the
Patriots front office would be ecstatic
with how it turned out and indeed they
were they were also disappointed deeply
so in themselves
Brady's surprising abilities meant that
the Patriots scouting reports were way
off for all their evaluations of players
think somehow missed or miscalculated
all of his intangible attributes they'd
let this gym wait until the sixth round
someone else could have drafted him more
than that they didn't even know what
they were right about Brady until
injuries knocked out Drew Bledsoe their
prize starter and forced them to realize
his potential so even though their bet
paid off the Patriots honed in on the
specific intelligence failure that could
have prevented the pic from happening in
the first place not that they were
nitpicking or indulging in perfectionism
they had higher standards of performance
to adhere to for years Scott Pioli
director of personnel for the Patriots
kept the photo on his desk of Dave stock
Chelsea a player the team had drafted in
the 5th round but who never made a to
training camp it was a reminder you're
not as good as you think you don't have
it all figured out staying focused do
better
bo Jackson wouldn't get impressed when
he hit a home run or ran a touchdown
because he knew he hadn't done it
perfect in fact he didn't ask for the
ball after his first hit and major
league baseball for that reason to him
it was just a ground ball of the middle
this is a characteristic of how great
people think it's not that they find
failure in every success they just hold
themselves to a standard that exceeds
what society might consider to be
objective success because of that they
don't much care what other people think
they care whether they meet their own
standards and these standards are much
much higher than everyone else's
the Patriots saw the Brady pick is being
more lucky than smart and although some
people are fine giving themselves credit
for luck they weren't in this instance
instead of celebrating they're
congratulating themselves they put their
heads back down and focus on how to get
even better this isn't necessarily fun
by the way it can feel like
self-inflicted torture sometimes but it
does force you to always keep going and
always improve for us the scoreboard
can't be the only scoreboard Warren
Buffett has said the same thing making a
distinction between the inner scorecard
and the external one your potential the
absolute best you're capable of that's
the metric to measure yourself against
your standards are winning is not enough
anyone can win but not everyone can be
the best it can be
think of the times that you've excused
your own behavior with no one will know
because it's not about what you can get
away with it's about what you should or
shouldn't do a person who judges himself
based on his own standards doesn't crave
the spotlight the same way as someone
who lets applause dictate success a
person who can think long term doesn't
pity herself during her short term
setbacks a person who values the team
can share credit and subsume his own
interests in a way that most others
can't reflecting on what went well or
how amazing we are doesn't get us
anywhere except maybe to where we are
right now but we want to go further we
want more we want to continue to improve
this is a characteristic of how great
people think
you
[Music]
you